empezando con la figura mostrada realiza
las siguientes transformaciones rotación
alrededor del punto 1 - 2 por un ángulo
de 93 grados traslación por el vector
menos 8 menos 6 reflexión a través de la
línea de igual a 3x la figura
transformada es congruente al original
bueno sin necesidad de hacer todas estas
operaciones les puedo decir que como no
estamos aplicando la o motes ya el rotar
trasladar y reflejar una figura no va a
modificar sus dimensiones
entonces sí sí va a ser congruente sin
embargo vamos a analizar cada uno de
estos elementos para confirmar tenemos
nuestras herramientas aquí abajo
traslación rotación reflexión o potencia
y deshacer pero vamos a analizar esto en
nuestro pizarrón aquí tenemos el
problema lo primero que nos dice en
rotación alrededor del punto 1 - 2 por
un ángulo de 93 grados vamos a ubicar
este punto sobre el que va a rotar
nuestra figura es el punto 1 coma menos
va a ser nuestro punto y va a rotar 93
grados como voy a saber yo qué es lo que
va a rotar voy a dibujar un círculo que
tenga este centro y voy a hacer que
coincida con algunos de los puntos de
esta figura por ejemplo con este en otro
color voy a poner que coincida con este
punto de acá de algo así y otro para
éste vamos a usar un verde tenemos
nuestro mismo punto de rotación y vamos
a hacer nuestros círculos que coincidan
entonces esta figura va a moverse va a
girar hacia arriba porque es un ángulo
de 93 grados un poquito más de 90 grados
pero cada uno de estos puntos va a estar
encima de estos círculos por ejemplo
tengo este punto que está en 3 - 2 éste
va a girar sobre este círculo rojo es
decir si yo tengo a partir del radio
dibujo una línea que coincida con este
punto yo
este lo voy a recorrer 93 grados que es
un poquito más arriba de este punto y
aquí este punto de la figura va a quedar
acá quedaría más o menos algo así ahora
este otro punto sobre el círculo
amarillo pues haríamos lo mismo vamos a
unir este punto con el centro del
círculo de rotación está acá
y esto lo voy a rotar 93 grados un
ángulo un poquito más allá de 90 grados
que 90 grados sería aquí en la
perpendicular de esta línea y lo voy a
hacer un poquito más grande entonces
quedaría por acá más o menos el punto
eso es un aproximado o sea no tengo un
transportador para saber exactamente
cuáles son los grados pero bueno creo
que esta es una buena aproximación ahora
el punto que se encuentra más lejano
este de aquí voy a unir el centro del
círculo de rotación con este punto y voy
a tratar de recorrerlo 93 grados que
bueno 90 grados es la perpendicular que
es más o menos por acá lo elevó un
poquito más más o menos así para tener
los 93 grados y aquí marco donde
quedaría el nuevo punto así es y ahora
lo que voy a hacer es unir estos puntos
que ya rote sea éste con
este este con este y este con este así
se vería mi figura esta que es la
original si la muevo hacia arriba pero
bueno quizás estoy llenando mucho la
pantalla con estos elementos pero si me
interesa que comprendan visualmente qué
es lo que significa esta rotación
alrededor del punto el centro de
rotación es este punto que me indica en
estas coordenadas y cada uno de los
puntos de la figura se va a mover cierto
ángulo hacia arriba en este caso 93
grados así que aquí quedó nuestra figura
rota ahora si hago la traslación por el
vector menos 8 menos 6 quiere decir que
cada uno de estos puntos voy a mover los
del eje x 8 lugares hacia la izquierda y
en el eje y 6 lugares hacia abajo cada
uno de estos puntos los voy a mover lo
más apegado que pueda acuérdense que
esto que estoy haciendo es una
aproximación con las herramientas que
tengo que bueno no son exactas
a este punto de acá que se encuentra más
o menos en la coordenada 10 la
coordenada en x la tengo que recorrer 8
veces hacia la izquierda va a ser 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 la coordenada ya la tengo que
recorrer hacia abajo 6 lugares por lo
que va a quedar 1 2 3 4 5 6 aquí va a
quedar este punto si lo recorro menos 8
que son 8 lugares hacia la izquierda y
menos 6 que significan 6 lugares hacia
abajo en el eje y muy bien este punto ya
quedo aquí ahora este otro punto que
tiene coordenadas 4 menos 14 si lo
recorre ocho lugares hacia la izquierda
va a ser 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 aquí y la
coordenada que es menos 1 si lo recorro
menos 6 o seis lugares hacia abajo va a
ser 1 2 3
va a quedar este otro punto ahora este
punto de acá está más o menos en la
coordenada 64 más o menos entonces la
coordenada x la recorro 8 lugares hacia
la izquierda aquí tengo 6 7 8 y la
coordenada de estar en 4 va a quedar 6
lugares hacia abajo así que aquí tengo 4
5 6 va a quedar aquí y ahora sí 1 todos
estos puntos voy a ver cómo quedó mi
triángulo o mi figura trasladada de aquí
acá de aquí acá y de aquí a acá muy bien
ahora lo que nos dicen reflexión a
través de la línea igual a 3 x tengo que
ver cómo es esta línea para sobre ella
hacer un reflejo de esta figura ahorita
lo vamos a ver
vemos que la línea es tiene una ecuación
ye igual a 3 x bueno para hacer esta
línea lo que es más fácil es ver cuánto
vale ésta cuando x es igual a 0
si x es igual a cero eso es igual a cero
por lo que también será hacer aquí está
un punto donde mi línea ahora supongamos
que x va a ser
3 acá sí aquí sí es igual a 33 x 39
lleva a ser igual a 9 así que tengo este
punto 3 y me voy hasta 9 aquí tendría
otro punto de esta línea que no me está
quedando muy preciso vamos a quitar esta
parte para que se vea como un punto ok
ahora lo que voy a hacer es unir este
punto con este para tratar de hacer
nuestro eje de reflexión cuál es la
línea en la que tengo que hacer la
reflexión tomo este punto lo uno con
este y lo extiendo porque me interesa
que se vea dónde va a estar nuestra
figura entonces si yo dibujo una línea
perpendicular de cada uno de estos
puntos hacia esta línea de reflexión mi
imagen reflejada va a tener esta misma
distancia perpendicular pero de este
lado por cada uno de estos puntos vamos
a hacerla ahora en un color que será un
rojo un rojo para que se note entonces
tengo este punto de acá y voy a dibujar
una línea perpendicular acá y la voy a
extender un poquito para que me ayude a
la imagen reflejada más
es así éste también una línea más o
menos perpendicular le extiendo y ésta
ha quedado muy juntita pero también voy
a extender más o menos esta línea
perpendicular un poco más y ahora voy a
dibujar cada uno de los puntos más o
menos a ojo quedaría más o menos por acá
el punto de este otro sobre esta línea
más o menos la misma distancia de este
lado quedaría algo así y de este punto
quedaría más o menos quedaría algo así
así que el resultado final de la figura
rotada trasladada y reflejada sería algo
más o menos así algo así y algo así muy
bien ahora regresemos a la aplicación y
veamos qué pasa cuando pongo todo esto
en las herramientas que ya están hechas
vamos a bajarnos un poco y hagamos
primero lo que nos indican la rotación
del punto 1 coma menos 2
un ángulo de 93 grados ok aquí está si
lo comparamos con nuestro ejercicio aquí
está este es el triángulo rotado que más
o menos queda parecido como está en la
herramienta ahora la siguiente es la
traslación por el vector menos 8 menos 6
ahí está esta es la traslación vemos en
nuestro ejercicio si aquí está más o
menos ahí baja y va finalmente la
reflexión aquí nos están pidiendo dos
puntos de la línea de reflexión y
nosotros ya los habíamos calculado en el
pizarrón un punto era el 0 0 y otro era
el 3,9 los ponemos aquí 0,0 y 3,9 y aquí
vemos la figura que queda al final que
es casi igual a la que hicimos hacia mal
nuestra respuesta es de que si las
figuras son congruentes y ya lo sabíamos
porque nunca aplicamos su potencia nunca
se modificado las dimensiones de esta
figura comprobamos la respuesta y si es